it is time to
play who he play for hey let's hear it
from the studio audience
hey I wasn't sure if you was going to
catch that
microphone I didn't know if you catch
that microphone that was pretty good oh
Rob is always right on target audio Rob
thank you for the uh for the non-working
game show microphone um so all you fans
at home uh if you haven't seen this show
um but I assume you have it's it's
really rather simple Charles we just
quiz Charles we have five players who
switch teams in the off season and all
he has to do is tell us who the new team
is and most of the time he gets what one
or maybe this is the number I'm going
with this is my year Z zero this this is
to year the chucker going to rise up
Cher you know what chuckster I feel good
about you way AR no no look I know the I
know the guys that we've selected and I
have a feeling thank you Arnie that you
are going to knock down two or three of
these there you go Ernie all right he
know he could he could he would fail who
he coached for all right so let's see
where oh here we go right are we ready
upstairs with player number one let's
see him it's ran holes ran holes so easy
ranol
used to see him in Sacramento oh no you
know what you didn't see him I saw him
in the you weren you weren't with
me m I'm not going listen to you fool uh
OKC OKC let's go with the Brooklyn Nets
let's go instead with the Dallas
Mavericks I gave you the answer Chu I
got four degrees I'm trying to help
you to help you
how I this one this is one of those that
I think think he's going to get it he
ain't going to get it I I think you're
going to get it Joe Eng Les oh that's
easy Joe Les remember played with the
Bucks last year play last Detroit
Detroit the Utah
Jazz once upon a time but now he's with
the Orlando Magic oh it's not who who
did he I thought he might have went
back got D good guess you're over to I'm
feeling he didn't play much I'm not
feeling as good about my prediction we
got three chances brother yes we
Lonnie walk the Brooklyn Net you have
got a
correct get him
CH Underdog no he didn't I heard it I
heard he had a decent game yesterday
yeah he did have a good game that's how
I know good all right uh he does not
know I don't know what kind of game Tory
Craig had for his team who's Tory Craig
play
for I'm going to go with the Sacramento
Kings oh so close it's the Chicago oh my
God got blown out the other day they had
a team meeting after the game one that
ain't good y'all listen I didn't know to
correig with W they got blown out I
stopped watching in the first qu and our
final our final is a who he play for
Hall of Famer in this every year every
year you baby Hey Garrett Temple is now
on his 12th team wow did he break trucky
Brown who is it I'm going go
with the Detroit
oh my goodness it's not far away it's
the Toronto R he he had another country
yeah hey your favorite City Toronto my
favorite city in the
world black Christine Simpson one up and
four down you were right on that one
that's F congratulations on getting joe
correct was Lonnie Walker wasn't you
missed Joe Engles too okay so you got
light